hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to liquidators warning every
second is automatically saved all
actions and decisions are permanent
extreme care and patience
is advised
i mean i'm gonna do my best but i
i can't make any promises this is me
we're talking about here i don't really
know what i'm doing walk run flashlight
interact crouch crawl drop carry
valerie only i don't know
valerius proximity detection amen
atmosphere radiation maximum health
radiation damage
so if you didn't know this is a game
about
chernobyl and the explosion of the
reactor there and the liquidators unless
i am mistaken are people that went in
to fix it or at least contain it
actually you know what i should do um i
should actually do my research so i'm
not talking about my ass about that
chernobyl liquidators were the civil and
military personnel who were called upon
to deal with the consequences of the
1986 chernobyl disaster in the soviet
union on the side of the event the
liquidators are widely credited with
eliminating limiting both the immediate
and long-term damage from the disaster
surviving liquidators are qualified for
significant social benefits due to their
veteran's status many liquidators were
praised as heroes by the soviet
government and the press while some
struggled for years to have their
participation officially recognized so
this is gonna be unfun it's gonna be
grim i imagine there has been a nuclear
accident in the soviet union and the
soviets have admitted that it happened
the soviet version is this
one of the atomic reactors at the
chernobyl atomic power plant near the
city of kiev was damaged and there is
speculation in moscow that people were
injured and may have died the soviets
may have been fairly quick to
acknowledge the accident because
evidence
in the form of mild nuclear radiation
had already reached beyond the soviet
borders to
scandinavia
great radio transmission connected and
working
to summarize you've been chosen because
of your expertise in locating valve
systems and reaching those water tanks
our last hope in containing this
disaster
if you don't drain these water things a
steam exposure will create a radioactive
fallout that will render europe
uninhabitable it is a perilous journey
to those valves and if anything happens
to you we will guarantee your families
are taken care of in your state
your country and i thank you for your
selfless service
okay
i don't know what you mean by i am an
expert with valves and locating the
thereof what am i
am i doing something
skip
oh main objective find the correct
valves to drain the water tanks there
should be a total of six valves four on
the main floor and two in the bottom
floor within the water tanker room the
bottom floor is sealed from heavy
pressure until the four valves in the
main floor are turned
oh
good
he's got an ability of crawl he's got an
ability of endurance he's got an ability
of electrician
okay i don't know why only he can crawl
i'm gonna take the tanky dude because i
have a funny feeling i'm gonna need it
on the first go of things and i guess i
shouldn't well i mean i don't know how
much electricity is in valve turning but
it's like this guy having been a
military veteran he has more endurance
and vitality than the average person one
committed liquidator added time to lower
risk and maximize efficiency
okay
oh here i go then
oh god
oh my god let me out
leon all right fine
easy i just gotta find some valves he's
dark
now i don't imagine that there are
monsters in this game but i think the
concept itself is spooky enough as it is
radiation is just such a like an
invisible horror
anyway
why is it so dark i don't know oh i do
have a flashlight
okay good at least they give me that
okay i'm just gonna go down here where
there's definitely oh i can i can crawl
can i oh i
only he can crawl in there
ah
okay
okay
oh boy this looks good hey how are you
doing oh
wow
is that a valve is that a valve i need
to turn
okay
hey
ah
[Music]
okay job well done let's go home then
i'm so excited to see my family
oh god
that is an ominous sound
i am and should probably be worried
about that
that's fine
that's totally fine hi what are you
oh oh god
oh god
so there's radiation in there not ideal
um i remember i saw the like netflix
show
about chernobyl great show by the way
but harrowing i think harrowing is the
only way to acknowledge it
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
am i okay no probably not hi okay hi hi
means bye i means bye everybody if that
thing on the bottom left says hiya that
means bye i gots to go
i gots to go
we know you've lost your family and we
cannot imagine what you've gone through
since
but we are here
and we will remain with you the whole
way
to the end of the line
what do you mean you lost my family i
thought you said you my family was going
to get taken care of you said that they
were going to be fine that's what i was
persuaded to do this
what do you mean
all right fine oh god
okay well water is a good uh
protector of radiation
so i've heard
is this a good thing is this a good
thing am i drowning this is a good or
bad thing
should i go into this i feel like that's
an open electrical arc which means that
if i'm in the water when that goes off
it's probably bad
oh god no oh wait wait hold on hold on a
second wait i didn't realize what the
game was hold on wait no you you didn't
you you you you you oh
no
okay is it going to go any higher than
that
it is presently going higher than i
gotta go okay can i turn this off
can i undo
oh my god i can't undo oh no
oh no
okay i gotta get to the other side i'm
sure i'm sure of it i just gotta get to
the other side that's all i gotta do
okay where am i oh no
oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
and after all that encouraging
statements about my family
well
good thing they don't save my progress
immediately unconscious
he's fine okay let's get valerie's crawl
with years of experience with
maintaining the vents and ducks he can
comfortably squeeze in and use them for
some safer routes i'm sure i can
as much as i regret it
i command
not going after him
but as your superior i allow you to do
so if you have the opportunity you might
be able to treat him at the hub area if
you drag him there the choice is up to
you
i can go get
what
i can go get him how do i crawl there we
go
i can go get him you said
how can i go get him and why is this
does this just loop back on himself
you know it's really funny that this
would just loop back on itself because
the only purpose that i can see for that
would be to hide from a monster and try
to lose it uh because you know that's
that's what that's been used before in
horror games but you know i can see how
that wouldn't actually be the thing that
you would have me do
here
so that would just be ridiculous
um boris
boris
boris
forest
forest
okay i got boris um
okay i'm gonna take him back
i don't know why
i the problem was i didn't go into the
room to see what i needed to turn the
water on i was just found a button and i
thought press the button because the
button means
game progress but maybe i'm reading too
much into it how do i get them back to
the hub
[Music]
is this the hub can i rev revive him
maybe if i take him back
here
hello
ah revive
revive
reviving
good job buddy
you're killing it you're killing it
you're killing me okay whatever i need
to stop getting
bogged down in these details there has
to be something in here
that i can utilize but only when the
water is rising but i need to find out
what that is first
and then not stand around and wait for
it to get incredibly deep that's that's
also what i need to do
um
oh i see a silhouette of a vent
hello
hi
is me
not boris
can you help me
why does that look like blood why does
it look like blood hello
okay that didn't seem like a safer route
again the crawl space seems to only be a
thing where i would um be running away
from a monster
that seems like the only thing that
would be uh good not that i think that
there will be monsters in here because
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
considering what this actually is but
i'm just
i don't know i just got this feeling
because why else would that be there
okay so that i can't press yet
maybe when i press that i can go in that
vent and then as the water rises i can
like float up i don't know if i can
float but if i float up and i'm able to
do something because this is yellow
which means that i can't press it yet
these are valves but these aren't things
that i can turn
let me try this crazy plan of mine and
i'll see what happens
i'm gonna try to first
see if this is impressible now nope
okay
well this is horrible
definitely up there in terms of
nightmares
huge nightmare potential
okay so if that fills up
then maybe
maybe just maybe this
is bad bad bad idea bad idea oh it was
wrong i actually can't i can't i can't
with this i can't i can't i can't can't
fading fast
i'm in a tunnel no one can get me
ah this is freaking tough
next subject
i thought you said volunteer
i thought you said that this was going
to be a volunteer thing has precise
knowledge of the electronics and fuse
boxes of the location resetting the fuse
boxes concerns some of the electronics
it could be beneficial oh well you
should have gone first still weed you
should have gone first
why were you waiting in the back also
what do you mean
so when you say precise location do you
mean that i can actually like
oh
do i have a map
i'm guessing i don't have a map
i'm guessing you don't you're not you're
not going to give me a map
oh hey
wow
to call the electrical engineering
school to just be able to press a button
like that
that doesn't seem quite right but then
again i'm not an electrician so i don't
really know what's about a complex
button now let's see if i can grab them
maybe i could reach just like maybe
don't worry
i can't even climb up this one ledge
[Music]
really i can't even
i can't jump
uh well i guess sorry pal i can't reach
you i guess what the hell
no not there
yeah it's like a death trap if i do that
i'm just gonna get stuck and die
and i can't go in this way because it
wouldn't make a difference
because i can't fit in there
well sorry pal um
yeah you know what i mean ye you know
you know what i'm talking about ye
um maybe i should just made a gun i
should have gunned it over here why
can't i get up there
seems a little ridiculou well i'm gonna
throw someone else into the wings i'm
going to do the thing where i press a
button and i'm just going to go across
the room i think the puzzle here is is
that there are things in the water that
can impede my progress if i don't pay
attention to it but then again maybe not
let's throw another person into the
wings
i'm going for it
shockingly i am once again going for it
oh it does open oh i'm very dumb
i see i see i see
okay excuse me
pardon me
pardon me hey valve wow
ha ha
would you look at
find the way that the next drainage
ralph okay you got it pal but how do i
get back to my buddy
oh god i'm gonna gun it
hey it's fine oh god it was not fine
turns out it was not fine well we're one
man down
but that's okay why is this a spike wall
i just had a horrifying spike wall but
that's okay because hey
it's all for the greater
good i know this may not be a good time
but your wife wanted to speak with you
she's on the radio now hi hi honey i
didn't want to distract you
i just
wanted to hear your breathing
one more time
[Applause]
one one more time
what am i i'll give you all the breaths
i got
i know how much you love my breathing
what was that
what is that what is going on here
what is the name of this
what is that
that's fine that's fine hearing a lot of
breathing hair what do you mean error
what do you mean error what
what do you what do you mean error
what do you mean
what
what what what
what what was that
oh is that the elephant foot
is that the aloof oh my god that's the
aloof and foot isn't it the elephant
foot
oh no
oh no oh god oh god
okay don't look at those
because uh that's bad
hey is that health is that big healthy
hey look at that
whoa
[Applause]
health
well that's good
oh god okay don't
oh my god
don't look at that [ __ ] oh my
flashlight's out of batteries or it's
not working here okay i can't see
anything ah
ye
okay
hey i can crawl in here somehow
can't see anything though
oh boy
oh i hope i'm going the right way
[Music]
okay so that's the that's not good oh i
can't go through here
are you kidding me you would let me
crawl through the other space but i
can't crawl through there i gotta go all
the way back damn you
what if they got a window there
why can't i vault i'm gonna get an error
error amounts of radiation i'm gunning
this oh wait this is fine
that's not fine this is also not fine
what kind of cat ass cat is that
what is that a cat oh god i've made no
progress i've gone not the right way
i've gotten the unright way
did i just make it back to the beginning
did i just go back to the goddamn begin
oh my i'm gunning it
oh ow
the cat killed me lost contact with
alexi i don't know
next recruit recruit thought we were
volunteers and then i thought we were
then you said we were something about us
being subjects well this is ungood what
happens if i just gun it through here
what's a little radiation oh no
radiation nothing
is nothing was there actually something
here was there a point to this why did i
get over here oh
that's fine yeah oh that's fine
that's fine i got the endurance for it
i got the endurance for which
means something
okay i'm gonna go through here now oh
god oh god oh god
is there something in here oh my god is
there something in here with me
don't touch it well i can't see anything
ah we
oh no
lost contact with all workers activating
emergency retreat evacuate all area near
chernobyl and beep beep
mission i
i see that now
um
i didn't really understand the mission
at hand
uh as it turns out i was not prepared
for this chernobyl nuclear reactors have
been fully eradicated from internal
meltdown radioactive fallout of europe
has begin oh
[ __ ]
countries affected
ukraine
belarus russia hungary sweden
norway finland
czechoslovakia germany estonia
poland latvia lithuania moldova as well
it's all of them yeah i'm just gonna go
ahead and basically say it's all of them
that's more than two
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ah
well you've done it you made me feel
really bad about my actions which i
think is the point of this it's so
fascinating to have a horror game that's
based on something that is actually a
very real thing but is a terrifying
concept this invisible un like you can't
even tell it's happening when it's
happening just being somewhere is
poisonous to the extreme
it's actually
eyes pretty scary it's pretty scary okay
now i better understand this there's six
valves four in the main floor two in the
bottom within the water tank room bottom
floor is sealed from heavy pressure
until the four valves in the main floor
are turned on
okay
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna get
valerie over here because valeri with
the crawl ability actually did seem or
maybe i should have taken the
electrician
can i can i hot swap can i swap hotly
can i quickly hot swap
uh
can i
i guess i can't okay i can't that's okay
i should have gotten the electrician
first because then he could have turned
on some lights and i wouldn't have had
to use so much of my
battery but now that i know that there
are definitely no monsters lurking in
the darkness i'm gonna be fine
i'm gonna be just fine
a-okay even
maybe even more than a-okay but i'm also
gonna go this way first
because as much as i uh don't like the
the bleeps and blorps if i don't touch
it
i should be okay
oh crawl
yeah it's fine i'm i've got some kind of
an armor on me
my father
i wanted to say that i'm very proud
the state does not deserve me you
goddamn right they don't
thanks papa
oh god
oh
why
oh my god okay wait no this was the
wrong place to go i thought this was
gonna be oh god i can't see anything
ah
okay some to my right
very heavy to the right okay left oh god
okay so ah that's what it is it's like a
mo
it's like i'm playing iron lung it
totally is
it's totally like i'm playing iron lung
is one whoa is 100 oh my god the
radiation damage
oh my god i wish i could see anything
can i please nah
it's donezo
oh god
oh god
oh my god
why did you get quiet
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god okay
hey i made it i don't know if anyone
could have made that but it's valeri
okay
thank you good
god great
great actually
this is another flashlight can i have
that okay cool what does that do what
does this do what is this whole place
what kind of power generating [ __ ]
is this
what does this button do
ah
okay so that was the uh the ladder from
before that can let me get up here but
what was down here there's a big red
door
a big ominous red door
and that goes somewhere
what are you
ah this must be a return somewhere else
okay
all right then i'm just gonna you know
i got a few wounds i gotta i got some
oozing radiation um but i'm you know i'm
doing all war never mind
doing poorly
now i'm doing okay
yippee
[Music]
i think this is where i came out before
and i think that means that this way
is uh the
the elephant foot area but if i keep
going left oh my god oh my god
if i go left
yeah if i go left and avoid the cat the
cat the cat stop
oh my
god i keep going this way no no no no no
oh my god okay
i just got to crawl for some reason i
was able to go through here before i
don't know why but i'm valeri now and i
can make it through here man that's
the number on the bottom of my
thingamabob is a big number it wasn't
quite such a big number before it was
kind of a big number now i gotta i gotta
duck under this window or else i'm gonna
get blasted
because i'm pretty sure that that might
be the elephant's foot
please no oh my god where am i
why am i circumventing this thing so
hard
oh just where is it
i don't even know
oh yeah that's ah that's it okay so it's
over there so that's good um that means
if i go here yeah what are you
i don't know
button no
oh how does this help me
how
[Music]
oh how does this help me
how would
what is the point of coming back here if
all of it is still death maybe there's
like something to do with going through
here if i just
hop
okay here what's here anything what are
you a lamp
was there a point to this i feel like
there wasn't a point to this because
it's right there and i'm right here and
that's real bad
unlike a few radiation gooshes i am
right back where i goddamn started
what was even the point of that entire
endeavor
[Applause]
i can't even jump so what would any of
that do oh
so somehow
i have to get
uh
through there would be nice
oh never mind that would be very bad
wasn't there some other way over here if
i yeah through here if i crouch here
okay
okay this is different it's a maze but
whatever it's do
oh god okay
yeesh um
oh my god okay i'm eating
hey
ah
still bad still bad still bad still bad
still bad is there another way out of
there what's with catwalks on the
ceiling well they're not on the ceiling
but you know what i mean they're above
me which might as well be the ceiling
i'm out of here
i don't think there's a back way
i think it's all just the same kind of
bad
give ha-ha
take that radiation
i ate my wheaties
ah
okay we're good we're good we're out of
here we're out of here we're out of here
baby
we're out of here baby
stressful
very stressful
incredibly stressful my lamp is still
dead but very stressful there was
another oh there probably was a way
through there but i think it's it must
have just opened that door somewhere to
get above the catwalks but i don't know
this is the return back there's only one
more valve to turn and i know where it
is because i was already over there it's
through the water and then the
downstairs will be unlocked
i got this one character no problem
i should probably get another lamp
[Music]
okay
all i get to do is make the mad dash
through the water but that was easy
enough last time so
yeah i'm going for it
[Music]
come on come on come on
i think he's a little shorter than the
other ones
oh god yeah i did not make his good time
here
or maybe that can't tell whatever boom
easy done
done
done
i'm doing it
i'm doing it i
i i think i don't know the way he was
hopeful again my gamer instinct is
telling me that it wasn't as good as it
sounded in fact it might actually be bad
why would that be the thing that you did
why did i hear a giant kaboom
who could possibly be giant and
kabooming
also why do i have to do everything
don't i have two other teammates that
want to swap out
i want to tag out
tags tag outsis
i can't push that for some reason
i can't read that
that's not good
oh
okay
oh it's weirdly nice here
what do you mean
what are you what are you talking about
weird ethereal groaning above my head
what do you what are you
what are you trying to say to me
is this russian are you speaking russian
huh
okay oh is that blood probably probably
probably
um
uh um interesting um what what
uh what
um what
what
[Music]
okay
i don't know
i don't know
i go up i guess am i supposed to go up i
feel like i was supposed to go down
didn't it say something about me
supposed to go down
[Music]
i think it did
i think i was supposed to go to the
lower levels where the two other pumps
for some high pressure [ __ ] reason i
was not able to access them but i am
able to access them if i go down
that's where i came from how did i just
go around and around like that
oh
right okay
going down
going more down
going even further down
continuing to go down
mori and mori
down
that's a big door
i saw a hefty door
that's a big hefty door
oh oh
i don't like that
i don't like that at all what is over
here what is this
why is this
why is everything gotta be so big and
terrifying what is that is that poop
that better not be poop
ah better not be poop water is this poop
water
what is it
so what
i will i will die
i i'll die i'll die i'll die why
i i will die so i guess i got to go to
the other one first
maybe
probably best not to die at this point
because it would be really hard to get
me back because i am literally so far
down this place
hello
hi
awfully well lit in here
oh good
[Music]
oh good good
good
why is it why is it brighter when my
lamp is oh
never mind i just had to say why am i
going up
i don't want to go up why would i be
going up up is not what i want to do
where am i
why am i here
i did not want to go here
why would anybody want to go here this
is how you get corpses back
this is the dead body return elevator
the de body return evader so am i
supposed to go into the um
place where i will definitely die
is that where i am uh supposed to go
oh
this is precarious
[Music]
this is precarious
this is precarious
you're doing it
don't
do it
always knew i could make it i never
doubted myself or even a mom
not one mom
not a mom hey this is a crawl tube
just my size it's almost like this hole
is meant for me
[Music]
as my whole
i didn't know that there would be uh
ethereal moaning here as what
[Music]
why
why is this the way that it is why would
you oh i see there was probably a
[Music]
is that the next valve
oh god please don't don't do it
i'm only about that i can't make that
fall can i
i'm guessing not
unless i
can
oh no
oh no i am drowning
i'm drowning
i'm alive
okay so don't do that because that was
dumb
understood
what if i go
i don't want to
i'm
go
again i'm
drowning again
i'm fine
i feel like i am bringing a little more
panic into this than there needs to be
that's what i'm believing right now
i made it okay so you go there but also
hi
i did it
i saved everyone
i saved us
you actually did it i did it
come out now
okay come out now you got it pal you got
it buddy um
yeah
i'm coming out now
me crazy son of [ __ ]
[Music]
okie dokie
[Music]
okay
all's well that ends well i suppose
i did it
did i go home now me and go home i go
home i could go home i get to go home
i get to go home
[Music]
am i do i get go home am i
can i slurp another one of these down
just in case
nope
okay
i guess i just go home
why wouldn't i go home
i am not okay
okay okay i did it right right
chernobyl nuclear reactor further
meltdown explosion prevented
predicted radioactive fallout of europe
prevented good
great actually
[Music]
additional liquidators and ah good and
volunteers okay good
yeah
alexianenko larry and boris were each
awarded the order for courage of the
third degree
i think i think these these guys were
also in the uh netflix series i think
an estimated 600 000 liquidators
participated in the worst nuclear
disaster in history all performing
incredibly important and daring duties
preventing an irreparable catastrophe
that would have affected tens of
millions of lives for generations
hundreds of thousands have died or
disabled due to the radiation doses
received while nearly all are suffering
from radiation complications
yeah radiation is scary it just is it it
just is it's terrifying it's like so
many things of our nightmares that we
make very few things that we can even
imagine are scarier than radiation very
good game kept me on the edge even
though that like i kept thinking that
there was going to be a monster but in
reality it's like nah
this [ __ ] just scary but also very fun
and scary thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
for some reason you want to play this
for yourself link is in the description
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]